la pénurie de professeurs cette fois
avant de débattre du manque
d'attractivité du métier d'enseignant et
des solutions
éventuellement inspirés de nos voisins
européens le constat le concours
d'entrée à l'éducation nationale ne
séduit plus sandra
pour la rentrée prochaine des milliers
de postes d'enseignants sont à pourvoir
10600 au primaire et 13 1690 dans le
secondaire du jamais vu et les
inquiétudes sont réelles certaines
disciplines sont plus touchés que
d'autres cette année seulement 816
candidats ont été admissibles au capes
de mathématiques pour 1000 35 postes
c'est deux fois moins que l'an dernier
en allemand et en lettres il manque
aussi des candidats admissibles
la réforme de l'accès aux concours
accessible au niveau master et non plus
à bac + 3 n'a pas aidé au contraire le
vivier s'est réduit ça révèle notre
activité en perte de vitesse concernant
les métiers de l'enseignement et c'est
vraiment les conditions de travail et
les conditions de de la profession qui
qui qui ne crée pas assez d'attractivité
qu'il faut revaloriser la fonction
d'enseignant aussi bien par le haut avec
les salaires que par l'autre côté c'est
à dire le versant aux compétences et
attractivité du métier il ya 40 ans un
professeur débutant gagnait trois fois
le smic aujourd'hui il commence sa
carrière avec un peu plus du smic soit
près de 1450 euros nets la rémunération
est un des enjeux principaux du
recrutement pendant la campagne
présidentielle emmanuel macron a promis
d'augmenter les salaires à 2000 euros
par mois tout en parlant de rémunération
au mérite selon les syndicats la
revalorisation des salaires et le
chantier numéro un du nouveau ministre
de l'éducation nationale ont pour
répondre à la crise des recrutements
n'est pas je présente mes invités de ce
site pour ce débat consacré à la pénurie
de professeurs à l'homme au manque
d'attractivité du métier d'enseignant
gérard longuet bonsoir sénateur de la
meuse rapporteur spécial de la mission
enseignement scolaire pour la commission
des finances et vous venez de remettre
votre rapport sur la crise
d'attractivité justement sophie vinadie
tu es bon soir vous êtes porte parole du
syndicat du second rss fsu eric delannoy
économistes bonsoir président fondateur
du cabinet tenzing engagés dans la lutte
contre les discriminations et la
promotion de l'égalité des chances
matthieu croissandeau toujours à mes
côtés évidemment est toujours
éditorialiste politique ce chiffre pour
commencer que l'on connaît un million de
da gens dans l'éducation nationale dont
800 mille enseignants pour 12,5 millions
d'élèves et sophie bénédicte et combien
de combien de postes manquants à la
rentrée est ce qu'on peut évaluer
combien d'enseignants vont manquer or on
sait qu'il va en manquer tout simplement
parce que c'est pas la première année
qui manque des enseignants ça fait
plusieurs années qu'ils on commence
l'année où il n'y a pas un professeur
devant chaque classe à la rentrée c'est
souvent aussi une situation qui peut
durer il n'est pas rare que on est des
classes qui par exemple n'ont pas eu
espagnols n'ont pas eu technologies
pendant plusieurs semaines ou plusieurs
mois ce qui est déjà en soi en ce moment
même une situation inacceptable
et là on voit avec tes résultats de
concours de recrutement que la situation
s'aggrave puisque par exemple sur le
concours de mead le capes de
mathématiques on voit que avant même
l'admission on a déjà perdu 200 postes
200 postes qui n'ont pas été pourvus
l'an dernier sur le capes de
mathématiques on avait perdu son poste à
l'issue de l'admission donc on voit bien
quand même que la pénurie se creusent et
aujourd'hui on est vraiment dans une
situation d'urgence on est à quelques
quelques mois de la rentrée on ne sait
toujours pas comment on va vraiment
pouvoir assurer cette rentrée on parle
beaucoup à juste titre un de l'hôpital
en ce moment des services d'urgence en
se demandant comment est-ce qu'ils vont
fonctionner même en constatant qu'ils
vont fermer nous on ne sait pas dans
l'éducation nationale comment nous
allons assurer la rentrée et surtout
comment nous allons assurer la suite de
l'année scolaire gérard longuet on
retrouvera évidemment dans le dans le
détail des deux de rapport et des
propositions et des évaluations vous
avez pu faire de nos voisins européens
c'est c'est passionnant et peut-être
surprenant pour certains mais j'ai envie
de dire comment on en est arrivé là est
ce que cette crise vous semble s'être
entre elles nous semblent plus critiques
que les précédentes moi je suis
rapporteur du budget de l'enseignement
scolaire depuis longtemps et je constate
que ce ne sont que depuis quelques
années que l'on commence à travailler
sérieusement ces questions d'une façon
de dire avec une approche de
gea pas scientifique mais et économique
et sur l'organisation
du système français hinse que nous avons
apportées cette cet instant au sénat la
commission des finances c'est une
comparaison avec le système étrangers
les systèmes européens principaux juste
une remarque on s'est toujours focalisé
sur le quantitatif et en particulier
pendant la présidence de françois
hollande qui souhaitait augmenter le
nombre de professeurs et je crois que le
vrai problème aujourd'hui la crise de
recrutement c'est qu'on ne s'est pas
intéressée sur le qualitatif c'est à
dire qu'est ce qu'être professeurs
aujourd'hui qui sont les élèves qui sont
les parents que sont les établissements
et comment gérer sa carrière donner du
sens à la qualité et à l'éducation à
coordonnées du change et puis réfléchir
à des conditions pratico pratiques qui
sont en effet décourageante pour les
enseignants on va évidemment en débattre
en d'état eric delannoy si on est dans
le constat en préparant les missions lui
dit il ya aussi la dévalorisation des
filières professionnelles pour pourquoi
selon vous c'est l'une des explications
ou une des causes des difficultés
actuelles on s'aperçoit d'un phénomène
dans les années 80 30 % d'une classe
d'âge aller jusqu'au bac aujourd'hui on
est à 85% alors c'est bien non alors
c'est bien ce c'est bien ça dépend pour
quoi faire parce que si c'est pour
amener une classe d'âge entières dans
des bacs dans lequel ans utilisant de
formation supérieure pour lequel en fait
ils n'ont pas été préparés par rapport à
leurs propres compétences leur propre
appétence oms on obtient une licence l1
donc la première année de 2
2 dans cette émission supérieur on a un
taux d'échec de 70% donc ça sert à rien
en revanche on a fait en prenant cette
disposition là en sorte que tout ce qui
n'allait pas dans la filière générale
pour aller dans des filières barque cdh
filières courtes et est dévalorisé dire
qu'en gros on les considérait plus
c'étaient les mauvais élèves qui
allaient et donc on a construit un
système élitiste extrêmement fort de
filières d'excellence versus de faiblir
pardonnez moi l'expression poubelle mais
alors quel rapport avec les profs parce
que donc les professeurs vont
majoritairement des fans n'auront plus
assez nombreux pour les filières
générales c'est le comprendre je alors
par rapport aux professeurs la
conséquence à l'est pas forcément
immédiate en revanche par rapport à
l'emploi c'est évident aujourd'hui on
manque de soudeur en france c'est quand
même incroyable manque de plombier en
france on manque de de deux jeunes qui
sont formés sur des filières courtes
très rémunératrice et qui ont du sens
parce que il n'ya pas de sot métier
qu'eux mais pour ce qui est des
professeurs on est sur un autre sujet la
massification d'enseignement forcément a
fait en sorte que potentiellement on n'a
pas fait suivre ni la formation des
professeurs ni leur évaluation ni leur
gestion dans les même ordre de grandeur
et on en arrive à un système dans lequel
ils sont un petit peu laissé les c'est
pour eux mais vous savez qu'un
professeur aujourd'hui et évaluer une
fois tous les sept ans une fois tous les
sept ans un professeur aujourd'hui les
progresse par le glissement vieillesse
technicité c'est à dire que l ancienneté
et c'est même pire que ça pour en avoir
fait l'expérience
j'étais dans des expérimentations de
d'expérience de prof à l'école surtout
ne dites pas de stage le prof à l'école
parce que cet âge est un terme bien
encadrés enfin il ya des normes du
bâtiment hallucinante bas on se rend
compte qu'il ya des professeurs bien sûr
ceux qui y viennent sont ceux qui sont
les plus à p temps à faire le lien entre
l'entreprise et la scolarité et on
s'aperçoit que ils nous disent tous que
ça n'est pas promu c'est à dire qu'on
les empêche quasiment de le faire parce
que vous comprenez il y en a qui le font
pas et c'est axa bref on est un système
qui s'est sclérosé dans le temps bon
allez on va rentrer dans le détail du
rapport qui sera publié demain gerra
l'engagement attendu priest vous pouvez
nous rejoindre
apport rebond soit qui dresse un
panorama de la situation des enseignants
au niveau européen oui tout à fait un
gérard longuet vous y dresser plusieurs
constats déjà d'énormes disparités
existent en matière de recrutement de
temps de travail de perception du métier
entre les profs des différents pays de
l'union européenne mais surtout vous
relever aussi une crise globale
d'attractivité du métier d'enseignant et
que vous expliquer par différents
facteurs vous allez le voir sur ces
infographies d'abord les salaires et
bien ils sont extrêmement variables
suivant les pays savary de 5000 à 80000
euros par an toutes catégories
d'enseignants confondues un danois par
exemple eh bien il atteint son salaire
maximum au bout de douze ans contre 29
ans pour un professeur français alors il
ya aussi vous allez voir les enseignants
qui ne se sentent pas suffisamment armé
pour réaliser leur métier à un tiers
d'entre eux se disent au niveau européen
ils estiment qu'ils ne sont pas
correctement préparé pour exercer leur
métier et résultat est bien il ya moins
de vocations le vieillissement même de
la population enseignante en témoigne la
part des professeurs âgés de plus de 50
ans a crû de 14 points en dix ans donc
ça c'est vraiment au niveau européen et
les professeurs français dans tout ça
voilà les gérard longuet dans votre
rapport vous les remettez aussi en
perspective en france vous allez le voir
il ya clairement une grille salariale
défavorable un pour les enseignants en
début de carrière leur rémunération est
souvent sous la moyenne européenne selon
l' ocde le salaire des enseignants du
primaire et du secondaire après 10 ou 15
ans de métier et bien il est inférieur
d'au moins 15% par rapport à la moyenne
de l'os et des oeufs en parité de
pouvoir d'achat vous avez aussi regarder
ce chiffre thomas au cours des 20
dernières années les enseignants
français ils ont perdu entre 15 et 25%
de leur pouvoir d'achat en euros
constants et dernier chiffre lui aussi
intéressants les salaires des
professeurs sont très inférieurs à ceux
du privé c'est -23% l'école élémentaire
et -12% au collège merci
j'attends pour tous ces détails gérard
longuet vous identifier deux motifs
principaux de la perte d'attractivité
lesquels j'ai vu faible rémunération et
l'organisation du travail l'organisation
du travail est très important titre est
distante je crois que le monde du
travail a profondément changé en europe
en général en france également et le
salarié était dans l' dans une économie
qui est de plus en plus tertiaires a le
sentiment d'être en gros plutôt mieux
associés et plutôt mieux considérer que
ses parents ne l'était pour les
enseignants ça rien n'a changé et
la relation avec les élèves étaient
difficiles nous sommes c'est très
intéressant nous sommes après le brésil
et l'argentine pour les pays de l' ocde
celui dont les relations entre les
enseignants et les élèves sont les plus
médiocres c'est à dire houleux où
l'enseignant a le plus de difficultés a
affiché sa mission son autorité sur des
élèves qui sont de plus en plus
difficile les parents sont difficiles et
l'école n'existe pas je veux dire par là
que on parle toujours de communauté
éducative cet amour merveilleux si ça
existait serait formidable mais le prof
se retrouve seul devant ses ennuis ces
difficultés et c'est quelque chose qui
n'arrive plus aujourd'hui dans n'importe
quelle entreprise privée il ya eu un
progrès et l'éducation nationale n'a pas
progressé de la même façon parce que la
bataille s'est toujours concentrée sur
les quantités un peu sur la rémunération
en sachant que nous avons toujours
privilégié le secondaire et le deuxième
cycle du secondaire et que nous avons un
peu sacrifié les instituteurs qui sont
devenus certes des professeurs d'école
des cadres eux à maisdon niveau salarial
est celui d'un brigadier de police ce
qui d'ailleurs très honorable le métier
enfin c'est c'est pas terrible il faut
pas s'étonner que ces enseignants qui
forment nos jeunes belles et forme
peut-être moins bien comme les ans les
enquêtes pisa le montre largement sophie
méditer est ce que vous faites le même
constat de sur l'isolément sur l'absence
finalement 2 j'ai pas de projet
collectif on quand on est dans un
établissement dans un collège dans un
lycée on travaille en équipe et
d'ailleurs on souhaite travailler en
équipe on voit bien que parce qu'on voit
bien que quand on a des élèves en
difficulté dans nos classes on va pas
résoudre tout seul ces difficultés là
parce que ce sont ces difficultés
difficultés qui ont plein d'explications
toute la question est de savoir est ce
qu'on a le temps de pouvoir travailler
ensemble est ce qu'on a le temps d'aller
voir le professeur principal de la
classe pour savoir lui quelle relation
il a pu avoir avec la famille est ce
qu'on a le temps d'aller voir
l'infirmière scolaire ben en fait on n'a
pas le temps d'aller la voir de toute
façon des infirmières y en a pas dans
les établissements scolaires donc ça va
être ça va être vite vu même chose pour
les psychologues de l'éducation
nationale donc la notion de collectif de
travail et la façon dont on veut
travailler ensemble elle est très
importante mais on n'a pas forcément eu
les moyens de le faire on n'a pas
forcément eu le temps de le faire et
vous parliez de la capacité d'adaptation
des enseignants moi je tiens quand même
à rappeler que en quelques années on a
eu un certain nombre de réformes des
changements de programme moi ça fait 12
ans que j'enseigne fil 3 sur le
changement de programme je pense qu'en
matière
d'adaptabilité on est capable de réagir
et on l'a fait et même s'il ya
évidemment des questions de conditions
de travail et des questions de sens du
métier aujourd'hui quel est le sens de
notre métier ça c'est une question qui
est absolument fondamental aujourd'hui
la première raison de la crise de
recrutement ça reste la question
salariale dans le premier degré comme
dans le second degré c'est quelque chose
qui pèse quand même vaincre et
lourdement g1 crise de recrutement
je vous entends je vous redonner la
parole éric mais ce qui est intéressant
dans le rapport c'est que même dans des
pays comme l'allemagne libyen où la
rémunération alors on peut voir les
chiffres on les a privés
50 % jusqu'en france est impressionnant
enseigné au niveau alimente élémentaires
en début de carrière on est à 65 milles
plus même 65000 475 euros bruts par an
en allemagne en france et 31 1803 alors
on est en brut 1 là évidemment c'est
moyenne enfin bon ça dépend des länder
enfin
vous avez supérieur de 30 à 40% et donc
j'ai au bout de la démonstration malgré
tout il ya une crise des vocations aussi
en allemagne oui parce que le métier est
un métier extrêmement difficile et que
les adultes préfèrent travailler avec
des adultes c'est plus gratifiant que
travailler les enfants ça c'est une
première difficulté là le en allemagne
ce qu'il faut savoir aussi c'est que les
enseignants font 35 heures ils font
moins d'heures de cours qu'en france
mais ils sont beaucoup plus présents
dans des établissements où laure accueil
est prévu où ils peuvent en effet poser
leurs fesses quelque part avoir un
bureau où ils sont où seuls ou
travailler en collectif mais dans tous
les cas ils sont dans l'établissement
alors que chez nous la tradition on
arrive on donne son cours et on s'en va
ce n'est pas la meilleure phase alors
oui
là dessus sur la gestion du temps dans
lequel on peut d'ailleurs intégré
peut-être les vacances oui là la durée
des vacances oui il ya un sujet en or
qui est à mon avis le même en allemagne
qu'en france qui est moins la question
de la solitude que la question de
l'accompagnement monde il peut revenir
eux-mêmes - aujourd'hui quand on parle
la question du sens qui est un vrai
sujet peut-on faire la même manière de
pratiquer le métier d'enseignant avec
l'ère d'internet qu'avant l'ère
d'internet mon à des jeunes qui sont
aujourd'hui tous des geeks quel que soit
le pelage à il arrive avec un niveau
d'information une capacité à gérer des
outils numériques avec des enseignants
qui ne sont pas toujours du même niveau
pas tous mais en d'ailleurs on l'a vu
pendant la pandémie c'était extrêmement
disparates et très compliqué donc les
méthodes pédagogiques et
l'accompagnement pédagogique
aujourd'hui ne suffit pas et quand on
parle du temps de réparation de travail
ce qui distingue l'allemagne de la
france et que 1 il ya des professeurs
qui sont multi enseignants dont il
associe ici généralement ils ont
plusieurs enseignements ce qui explique
la taille et son buisson multi minimum
l'illwald absolument
en 16 ans de présence et qu'ils ont une
présence plus importante dans la classe
mais en france on a beaucoup de vacances
pourquoi ne pas substituer des vacances
à des périodes de formation en fin
subtil potes parigo et son fils étaient
les vacances pour faire des bien sûr
parce que ce qui manque dans la cause
des conditions de travail de
l'enseignant c'est bien la formation
l'adaptation des méthodes pédagogiques
l'accompagnement la capacité à devenir
des classes qui sont de plus en plus
difficile et ça c'est effectivement
incroyable qu'on en parle finalement
assez peu dans cette approche
quantitatif contre lequel moi aussi je
m'insurge d'une approche budgétaire de
l'éducation nationale alors cette
question des vacances c'est un
marronnier c'est pas la première fois
quand vous qu'on vous pose cette
question mais effectivement ça peut
surprendre judici de mon siège de deux
observateurs de dire bon ben voilà il ya
beaucoup de vacances et les formations
ne sont pas forcément organisé pendant
pendant ce temps de vacances je sais que
c'est un marronnier et il n'y a aucun
problème pour pour y répondre d'abord
rappelé qu'ils aient le temps de travail
d'un enseignant qui ne se limite pas aux
15 heures ou 18 heures qu'on fait deux
ans les élèves dans la salle de classe
et c'est un iceberg il ya une partie
et les enquêtes les enquêtes du
ministère montrent que d'ailleurs ont
fait plus de 40 heures par semaine on
est à 42 eur 53 de travail quand on est
professeur en collège et en lycée et par
ailleurs on travaille aussi pendant nos
vacances c'est à dire que le fameux
travail caché la préparation des cours
les corrections des copies et sert à ça
se fait en partie pendant les vacances
dont croire que les vacances serait
cette espèce doazit complètement protégé
pendant lequel on couperait complètement
avec avec la réalité de nos métiers
c'est un fantasme et d'ailleurs si c'est
la question des vacances était
déterminante pour recruter on aurait
certainement pas la crise de recrutement
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui donc il faut
arriver à sortir un peu de ces de ses
clichés sur sur le métier d'enseignant
j'ai entendu beaucoup de choses hein sur
sur la réalité de notre travail et c'est
aux gens mais ils pardon je reprends
parce que je reprends là l'argument
d'avec de maintenant est ce que
effectivement il ya des difficultés
d'organisation difficulté présence des
professeurs dans leurs classes parfois
parce qu'ils sont en formation à cinq
jours mais parfois parce qu'ils sont en
formation menace il travaillait déjà
pour les vacances mais on pourrait le
formaliser sauf que si c'est pas quatre
mois et demi de vacances oisive et que
vous dites mais non on travaille pour
les vacances ça pourrait être formalisée
et donc du coup occuper ce temps que
vous passez à corriger des copies pour
les vacances à vous former par exemple
mais après il ya une organisation du
travail qui est propre à chacun qui
n'empêche pas de se former par ailleurs
tel un groupe se forme aussi à d'autres
moments parce que d'ailleurs la
formation et est plutôt plutôt
importante après sur sur les questions
de est ce qui se passe dans la classe et
j'entendais par rapport à la question du
sens du métier et des élèves aujourd'hui
finalement il faudrait aussi qu'on parle
des conditions de travail alors quand
vous avez des classes de 35 ou 36 élèves
serra et des classes de 35 92 élèves
pardon mais alors bon le quiz car
attention
ces 24 alors oui on doit pas parler du
même seconde ernst moi je vais encore
enseignante dans un lycée et j'ai un
certain nombre de collègues travaillent
dans des collèges et des lycées s'est
déroulée à fromelennes du ministère ce
sont des salles ayant tu mais il ya
compte tenu du nombre d'élèves et du
nombre d'enseignants là le taux moyen
d'encadrement c'est un professeur pour
24 à l'aise dans le secondaire et alors
là un jour 19 dans le prime la réalité
est bien celle du nombre d'élèves qui a
déserté mais c'est pas normal après ça
pose même la question des moyens
existent qu'elles aient calé le son un
comment est-ce qu'on exerce notre métier
le métier qu'on a choisi avec le sens
qu'on lui a donnée quand on a passé le
concours quand on a passé le concours on
s'est dit qu'on x 10 et ce métier pour
transmettre quelque chose à nos élèves
pour les faire réussir et après on se
retrouve dans des situations extrêmement
difficiles avec 30 35 élèves à gérer des
choses là en ce moment en tant
qu'enseignant on gère parcours sup je
peux vous assurer que quand vous avez
choisi d'être enseignant pour la
réussite de vos élèves et que vous devez
gérer les résultats de parcours sup en
ce moment vous ramassez vraiment on
ramasse les élèves à la petite cuillère
quand ils reviennent le lendemain des
résultats de parcours super l'a
forcément on se pose la question mais
qu'est ce que je suis en train de faire
donc la question du sens du métier elle
passe aussi par toutes ces questions de
réformes qui ont été imposées sur
lesquels on nous a pas écoutés mais si
on veut parler de son ancien métier moi
j'ai envie de dire à tout le monde j'ai
envie de dire aux députés aux sénateurs
j'ai envie de dire aux journalistes que
vous êtes à celles et ceux qui nous
écoutent qu'il faut aussi que la
revalorisation du métier d'enseignant ça
passe par la question des salaires ça
passe aussi par l' écoute et la
considération qu'on nous donnera quand
on tire la sonnette d'alarmé quand on
tient un certain nombre des choses c'est
ça aussi le match ça c'est juste mais
j'ai assez pas qu'une affaire de regard
de valorisation c'est quand même
paradoxal de se dire que les jeunes ne
veulent pas de devenir prof le métier
auquel ils ont été le plus confrontés
canton les jeunes ces profs on a passé
et pologne n'ont pas la majorité pas la
majorité des demandes a passé un certain
nombre d'heures de cours on libère au
goût au collège au secondaire voire dans
l'enseignement supérieur ils sortent de
là évidemment surtout pas j'ai pas envie
d aller s qui a pas quelque chose qui
tient aussi peut-être à au delà de ces
questions de valorisation parce qu'ils
n'ont pas forcément le salaire en tête à
la façon d'enseigner à la réalité du
travail à la
surprise quand ils apprennent la réalité
nos salaires oui j'entends dire mais
aussi dans la façon dont est ce que l'on
sait faire de procès d'intention est on
à l'ism est ce que voilà est-ce qu
est-ce que c'est un métier où on peut
évoluer est ce que c'est un métier où on
peut changer on n'a pas forcément ce
sentiment là parce qu'ils ont quand on a
une scolarité on voit monsieur ou madame
untel il fait de même pour man pendant
cinq dix ou quinze ans mais voir ce
sentiment là en tout cas dans les
fratries ab toi aussi tu as monsieur
untel toi aussi ça tout le monde a connu
ça on l'a vécu les uns les autres je
voudrais qu'on regarde quand même ce qui
se passe en ce moment dans certaines
académies pour combler cette fin de
trouver une solution à cette pénurie de
profs par exemple l'académie de
versailles qui veut recruter 1300
professeurs contractuels sur quatre
jours dont 700 pour le primaire et 600
pour le secondaire ses passions voileux
la petite annonce apparaître mais en
tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que
la rectrice de l'académie de versailles
cette lectrice elle s'appelle charline à
avesnelles elle a lancé un appel aux
candidats sur les réseaux les médias
sociaux regardez vous recherchez un
emploi un nouveau métier qui a du sens
l'académie de versailles recrute pour la
rentrée de septembre ceux qui
connaissent déjà le métier qu'ils
souhaitent exercer pourront passer des
entretiens pour devenir professeur en
école en collège en lycée accompagnant
d'élèves en situation de handicap
médecins ou infirmiers scolaires ou
encore psychologues de l'éducation
nationale
ceux qui veulent découvrir nos métiers
et peut-être se laisser convaincre pour
en venir échanger avec des personnels
contractuels qui ont déjà sauté ce pas
pour la rentrée de 2022 nous avons
plusieurs centaines de postes à proposer
alors venez nous rejoindre pour les
journées du recrutement alors ces
journées elles ont déjà eu lieu c'était
la semaine dernière à bien il ya aussi
un job dating qui aura lieu le le 20
juin prochain à beauvais qui souvent
pensé eric delannoy mais bon c'est pas
la première fois source et des pratiques
qui ont déjà eu lieu il ya même très
longtemps j'ai soixante dix de mémoire
donc
on sait me diront on s'improvise pas
prof quand même nom s'improvise pas trop
d'autant plus qu encore une fois
l'accompagnement pédagogique derrière va
faire complètement défaut donc donc donc
j'en pense que c'est des mesures
d'urgence sur lequel on ne travaille pas
sur les vrais problèmes aujourd'hui il
est vrai sujet c'est la rémunération
enfin de manière extrêmement claire faut
travailler dessus mais travailler
également sur la réparation du travail
et puis moi j'ai une question à poser
aujourd'hui on sait qu est ce qui incite
aujourd'hui un professeur à bien faire
son métier
rien mais rien donc là vous êtes sur
quoi sur la position de mairie
le mérite la progression les conditions
de travail je veux dire aujourd'hui il
ya une proposition qui est faite de
prendre en compte les données
territoriales c'est à dire la manière
dont on pratique le métier dans les
territoires parce qu'on ne fait pas la
même pédagogie dans le 93 que dans 60 18
ce n'est pas vrai d'accord il ya des
problématiques autour de la
disponibilité des professeurs qui sont
absents de leur évaluation de leur
gestion un professeur qui veut organiser
sa classe pour pouvoir je l' ai vécu ça
donc ce n'est pas des des poncifs qui
veut organiser sa classe pour aider des
jeunes à avoir le bac et de meilleures
notes au bac on va lui mettre des bâtons
dans les roues sur le thème ânonnant il
faut pas faire d'heures supplémentaires
parce que tu comprends tu donne le
mauvais exemple c'est pas possible ça ce
n'est pas possible alors
ce que vous avez trouvé dans les dents
dans l'étude des des exemples étrangers
je sais qu'il ya on a parlé de
l'allemagne et le portugal aussi je sais
pas si le portugal et l'allemagne pour
des raisons très simples
c'est l'exemplarité allemandes n'ont pas
en matière d'éducation mais la réussite
économique de l'allemagne nous ou eux
c'est facile ils ont de l'argent ils ont
moins de jeunes d'ailleurs il ya un
déclin démographique et martin or ils
ont exact bien qu'ils payent bien leurs
professeurs ils ont exactement les mêmes
difficultés que nous en terme de
recrutement inversement le portugal est
un pays intéressant parce que quand il
ira en 70 n'y avait pratiquement
tous par mois une majorité 60 70 %
d'analphabètes et le portugal à tout
rattraper sur une base complètement
différente c'est à dire avec des écoles
beaucoup plus autonome des écoles
regroupées qui sont à la fois primaires
secondaires et avec des enseignants qui
sont bien payés les portugais estiment
être mal payé mais qui sont
objectivement bien payés en particulier
en moyenne mieux payés que les salariés
du privé du même diplôme de même
qualification école autonome j'ai lu ça
dans le rapport ça veut dire que le chef
d'établissement à la main sur 25 % des
heures de course et ça sur les audois et
sur les rues de les impacts en quelque
sorte les heures de course au
recrutement vous habiller des systèmes
très différents par exemple prenez
l'allemagne vous avez des concours
nationaux vous avez des listes
d'aptitude et les responsables des
différents länder
choisissent et c'est un peu comme la
fonction publique territoriale il n'y a
pas de droit à rester dans le même
établissement c'est une un état d'esprit
différent c'est je voudrais revenir sur
la france il ya un problème extrêmement
simple qu'on ne sait pas réglé et qu'il
faudra régler immédiatement
c'est que les régions ne sont pas les
mêmes l'immobilier n'est pas le même en
ile-de-france et en lorraine pour je
parle de l'argent que je connais quand
vous avez des rapports de 1,5 pour le
coût du logement va forcément çà çà çà
intact le pouvoir d'achat les besoins
sont pas les les difficultés ou plutôt
les tentations de quitter l'enseignement
sont pas les mêmes selon les matières si
vous êtes professeur de latin
l'enseignement est à peu près le seul
débouché si vous êtes professeur de
mathématiques il faut beaucoup de
courage pour rester à l'éducation
nationale quand vous voyez toutes les
ss2i d'informatique qui vous demande
propose de venir travailler chez eux
pour beaucoup plus cher or nous savons
ni récompenser ceux qui sont dans des
zones difficiles ni encourager ceux qui
sont donc vous rejoignez ce que vient de
dire exactement il faut rémunérer
il faut une différenciation ce qui n'est
pas dans l'esprit habituel de la
fonction publique que de notre beau je
vais vous donner la parole mais je
voudrais qu'on n'entende finalement une
réaction parce que là on parle
d'autonomie de marge de manoeuvre des
des directeurs d'établissement c'est
aussi ce que propose le président la
république on va écouter un extrait
savoir si leur effet tellement on va
voir s'il va le faire en tout cas
c'était la semaine dernière 2 juin en
déplacement à marseille on écoute ma
belle macro l'école d'aujourd'hui elle
est une école déjà un multiple de
vitesse parce que vos situations sont
très différentes selon les quartiers de
la république
ensuite on a déjà donné des moyens
différents c'est quand on est en référé
plus c'est là se donner des moyens
nationaux on va faire sur la formation
sur patins de choses j'ai dit dès la
rentrée on va remettre par exemple
l'heure et demie de maths en première et
on va mettre le sénat demi heure de
sport en primaire partout la formation
les éléments de rémunération ça va être
partout on va bâtir ce nouveau pacte
mais après il ya des solutions qui
seront très différenciée sur le terrain
parce qu'ici la priorité c'était par
exemple sur les mathématiques parce
qu'on avait vu qu'ils avaient un besoin
enfin les professeurs et avec elle un
besoin dans d'autres écoles ce sera
ailleurs
sophie min tit et qu'est ce que vous
pensez de cette idée si je résume un peu
moins de verticalité plus de solutions
de terrain d'autonomie pour les
directeurs d'établissement puis après on
parlera de la question de la
rémunération au mérite pas au mérite la
sueur sur l'a1 l'autonomie ça recouvre
d'ailleurs plein de choses et on met
plein de choses derrière autonomie tels
que la présente emmanuel macron si on se
dirige vers une autonomie accrue des
chefs d'établissements notamment sur la
question du recrutement et là ça pose
clairement question ça pose même
problème d'abord comment est-ce qu'on
peut s'assurer qu'un chef
d'établissement peut savoir recruter sur
l'ensemble des disciplines qui a dans
son dans son collège et son lycée
qu'est-ce qu'il fait dire que et il va
être compétent pour savoir si untel est
un bon professeur d'espagnol ou un bon
professeur de physique-chimie ça veut
dire qu'il faut avoir un spectre de
compétences pour savoir si c'est un bon
professeur c'est une prophétie jours
quoi faire passer un entretien avec la
matière et a demandé sa mise adhéré au
projet d'établissement bassim professeur
c'est quand même série qui maîtrisent
engager leur fille non seulement après
sur sur la question du recrutement par
le par le chef d'établissement ça veut
dire que n'entre effectivement sur une
logique de concurrence qui n'est on
parlait tout à l'heure de travail en
équipe c'est quand même très paradoxal
en 30 minutes d'être passé de la
valorisation du travail en équipe à la
mise en concurrence à travers le
recrutement si on veut travailler en
disant qu'en créant ok mais la mise en
concurrence des professeurs pour savoir
s'ils adhèrent bruno richet au projet
sans lui mais on peut ranger entre les
établissements alors là ça pose quand
même ça ça pose quand même question ça
veut dire la question mais s'il n'y a
pas de liberté d établissement une
certaine émulation une certaine fierté
de la réussite de chaque établissement
vous ne crée pas une dynamique et un et
des projets la notion même de l'idée de
concurrence est une idée qui est pour
nous étrangère à la notion même de
service public le service public en tout
cas on peut avoir un avis différent sur
la question il est absolument aucun
souci ça je m'en doutais mai et comme
sur la rémunération mérite qu'on aura
l'occasion d'y revenir mais comme on ne
peut pas d'un côté parlé de solidarité
travail en équipe et posé tous les
jalons qui vont venir explosé or ce
travail ce travail en équipe surprise en
l'occurrence pour le cool il ya déjà une
expérimentation sociale si vous me
permettez j'allais chez vous le soir il
ya déjà une expérimentation de ce type
là en 2012 soutient kenan nicolas
sarkozy avec une expérimentation
d'éducation prioritaire le dispositif
éclair il y avait le recrutement
notamment d'un certain nombre
d'enseignants sur lequel le chef
d'établissement pouvez effectivement
avoir une voix prépondérante que s'est
il passé je prends l'exemple de
l'académie de versailles la plupart des
postes qui étaient justement profiler
comme ça à la main des chefs
d'établissements n'ont pas trouvé
preneur qui n'ont pas trouvé preneur
c'est à dire qu'il n'y avait pas y avait
même pas suffisamment de gens qui
candidatent et est ensuite ces postes-là
n'étaient pas pourvus donc de toute
façon on a l'expérience que ça ne
fonctionne pas d'ailleurs qu'il ya des
il ya des centaines de postes qui sont
restés vacants alors même qu'on a mis en
place cette expérimentation l'a donc
pourquoi vouloir reproduire quelque
chose qui n'a pas fonctionné sur le
mérite marc lemay la rassure mérite
alors sur le mérite déjà j'ai entendu
beaucoup de choses sur l'avancement des
professeurs mais des choses qui étaient
pas complètement de rien puisqu'il ya eu
notamment une réforme du statut qui a
conduit à un avancement plus rapide pour
l'ensemble des enseignants ça date de
2014 où l'on passait quelque chose qui
arrive c'est ça
et ceux qui l'étaient déjà avant large
et pareil là est ce que si si je peux si
je peux terminer d'écrire ensuite donc
il ya quand même un avancement qui est
qui et plus rapide ensuite sur la
question du mérite déjà une question
intérieure forte c'est à dire comment
est ce que vous allez définir quand vous
dites avant son purin vitres sur quels
critères l'ensemble des enseignants
avancent plus rapidement il y en a une
partie sur quel accord mais est-ce bien
ok il ya une partie je vais terminer il
tend alors si vous voulez me couper la
parole à chaque fois il y avait un
problème je remarque c'est vous me
laissez pas terminée en fait
banon vont me couper la parole à chaque
fois pour vous aider à préciser la
pensée parce que je le fais mais je vous
remercie mais je crois que peut le faire
tout seul
terminez votre phrase ou qu'il ya eu
effectivement une
l'avancement des professeurs est plus
rapide et une partie avance encore plus
rapidement sur la question du mérite il
ya quand même une question qui est de
comment est-ce qu'on définit le mérite
comment est-ce que vous définissez le
mérite d'un enseignant c'est extrêmement
compliqué c'est extrêmement difficile de
savoir comment est ce que vous faites
est ce que vous le faites en fonction
par exemple du taux de réussite aux
examens de votre classe mais vous savez
très bien que ça ne relève pas
uniquement du rôle d'un enseignant et
finalement à travers la question du
mérite vous mettez là aussi en
concurrence les enseignants les uns avec
les autres alors même qu'il faut qu'on
travaille ensemble moi si enfin on va
prendre des exemples très concrets
parliez tout à l'heure de la solitude
des enseignants etc si on sait que pour
être mieux rémunérés faut écraser son
petit collègues et je peux vous assuré
xavier motifs ça va être content eric
delannoy vous vous battez aussi le fait
que finalement le système tel qu'il
fonctionne actuellement il est à ces
inégalités acer que les élèves de
certains départements ont pas avoir les
mêmes chances que mais ça se dotera ça
c'est évident et de la joint sur un
point c'est que la composition des
classes a une incidence sur la réussite
de la classe ça c'est tout à fait vrai
mais mais mais cette mais pas seulement
enfin dans le 93 par exemple quand on
parle du primaire secondaire pour une
fin jusqu'à l'arrivée en seconde un
élève qui arrivent en seconde dans 93
par rapport à l'eau cumul des absences
des professeurs qu'il a dû subir dans ce
département la en moyenne bien
évidemment à une année de scolarité dans
moins au moins il est est ce que le fait
de rémunérer au mérite ça changera la
nausée il ya des endroits où le lien
social ne tient que par la vocation du
professeur tellement ce sont des
endroits très difficile saison c'est ces
gens là il faut les effectivement faire
en sorte de les inciter sinon on va se
retrouver avec des professeurs qui ne
voudront jamais aller dans des endroits
où l'enseignement est difficile donc le
mérite de son il ne s'agit pas de
construire un système parfait ça
n'existe pas y compris en entreprise le
mérite mais ne pas sous prétexte qu'on
ne peut pas évaluer le mérite de manière
parfaite et que ça risque de mettre en
concurrence et professeurs ne rien faire
masser juste continuer un système qui ne
fonctionne pas on a entendu les
arguments s'agit on a entendu les
arguments des uns et les autres je
voudrais terminer on est quasiment à la
fin de deux débats et c'est intéressant
mathieu je vais vous donner la parole
pour conclure parce que cette
désaffection qui touche le monde
enseignant m'a finalement et touchent
presque toute la fonction publique mais
oui autrefois on disait que les jeunes
arrivés tous d'être fonctionnaire
aujourd'hui plus personne ne lit même
pas ce que c'est plus car il ya encore
vingt ans dans une période de chômage de
masse en tout cas plus élevé
qu'aujourd'hui la perspective de la
sécurité de l'emploi jouait encore à
plein pour séduire les candidats aux
concours de la fonction publique
aujourd'hui celle inverse pénurie de
vocations chez les enseignants vient de
le dire démissions en cascade chez les
soignants pour ne reprendre que les
exemples qui s'étale à la une des
journaux c'est bien simple en fait
aujourd'hui il ya quatre fois moins de
candidats à la fonction aux concours de
la fonction publique qui lie à 25 ans et
encore il suffit pas de se porter
candidat il faut aller aux épreuves et
alors là aussi c'est la douche froide en
2010 9 40% un peu plus 40% seulement des
personnes qui s'étaient inscrites au
concours ont passé les concours ils
étaient encore 50 1% un an plus tôt et
alors comment s'explique cette crise des
vocations on en a abordé quelques uns il
ya plusieurs facteurs évidemment d'abord
est un facteur conjoncturel c'est en
période de baisse du chômage mais
il ya des moins de gens qui nous venons
de le vivre la fée de la fonction
publique fiphfp - figure de valeur
refuge a fait pas le poids surtout par
rapport au secteur privé ou sur le
strict plan des rémunérations et des
points de vue des perspectives de
carrière mais évidemment c'est beaucoup
plus favorable puis problème pour l'état
les collectivités territoriales ou
l'hôpital qui regroupe les cinq millions
de fonctionnaires c'est aspects
conjoncturels
ils risquent de durer parce qu'en plus
avec le vieillissement de la population
mais voilà il va y avoir de moins en
moins d'autres candidats il ya une autre
raison quand même c'est les conditions
de travail on en a parlé aussi pour les
enseignants des commissariats en état de
misère des tribunaux surchargés des
horaires interminables à l'hôpital la
dégradation dans laquelle l'électrode
agents publics exercent leur fonction
est non seulement épuisante mais aussi
désespérante il suffit d'écouter il
affirmé a raconté le temps qu'elle passe
aujourd'hui avec un patient à l'hôpital
par rapport à il ya dix ans pour le
comprendre comment on assure un service
public quand on a l'impression que ce
qu'on fait au mieux mal fait ou au pire
insuffisant inefficace voire inutile
mais c'est pas évident ça fait perdre le
sens de la mission d'une semaine passée
pour y remédier forcément un phare du
temps oui parce que ça nécessite une
réforme profonde de l'état de son champ
d'action de sa façon de fonctionner des
moyens qu'il y affecte en termes d'âge
en au personnel mais aussi et surtout de
la façon dont il les traite ses agents
parce que l'aspect ressources humaines
mais quand même très défaillant il
faudra en finir une bonne fois pour
toutes avec tout un nom de catéchisme
qu'on entend depuis 30 ans d'abord le
catéchisme qu'il pense et c'est à dire
d'emblée qui a trop de fonctionnaires
entendus pour la campagne présidentielle
250000 il faut en supprimer way est
pourquoi comment on sait pas où
al'inverse il faut aussi en finir avec
le catéchisme averses qui lit il faut
créer des postes de fonctionnaires le
dernier exemple c'était françois
hollande ont dit les allusions 60000
enseignants et pourquoi pas 70 90 quand
on aborde la réforme de l'état sous le
prisme du coup cessé de toute façon une
bêtise c'est pas comme ça qu'il faut les
marques phares faut arrêter aussi avec
un autre dogme qui voudraient nous faire
croire que appliqué à la fonction
publique toutes les théories managériale
parfois complètement bidon qu'on a
connue depuis les années 80 ce serait
une bonne chose dont la fonction
publique exerce une mission de service
public on peut pas tout gérer comme une
entreprise il faut s'inspirer parfois de
bonnes pratiques n'y a pas que ça
al'inverse il faut aussi arrêter de
penser il faut surtout toucher à rien et
que la fonction publique est un
sanctuaire est que rien ne doit évoluer
au nom de l'égalité sur tout le
territoire et l'égalité entre tous les
agents en clair faut essayer de
s'inspirer de faire preuve de
pragmatisme s'inspirer la meilleure
pratique décentralisées sans doute
expérimentés on l'a dit ça peut-être pas
marché à la fois peut-être qu'il faut
leur tente et une fois responsabiliser
salaires donné quand même plus
d'autonomie aux gens et puis revaloriser
bien sûr les feuilles de paye radis et
les carrières on va terminer avec vous
gérard longuet dans dans l'est je
reviens au portugal parce que moi c'est
peut-être ce que j'aime plus découvert
dans sera pas aussi qu'est ce qui vous a
surpris ce qui m'a surpris c'est la
volonté d'un gouvernement de permettre à
son peuple de rattraper un véritable
retard en matière d'éducation en sautant
quelque sorte une une étape n'ont pas
copié la france ils ont inventé quelque
chose de nouveau fondée sur la
responsabilité des chefs d'établissement
et d'ailleurs les cours des classements
pisa des élèves français et portugais se
sont croisés exact là ils ont dépassé
ouais bon ben voilà on peut terminer là
dessus est ce que vous
allez j'y vois si je dirigeais un grand
ministère la poste et les
télécommunications et un autre de grands
effectifs 1 l'armée l'armée sur une
maison bien gérée qui sait
assure mais d'aider la gestion des
hommes la poste et des télécoms ont
évolué et ont évolué vers des gestions
qui sont pour les télécoms totalement
privé pour la poste à ses proches de
l'entreprise pvmp ça peut bouger dans le
service public ce qui est mauvais c'est
l'inertie et la paralysie bon on va
terminer là dessus vous a vu les uns et
des autres la parole même si je pense
que vous n'êtes pas totalement d'accord
on a bien compris qu'il y avait deux de
vision qui qui s'opposaient ce soir
c'était passionnant en tout cas nous
entendre les uns les autres merci merci
encore d'avoir participé à ce débat